[muzyka]
czarne budynki czarne apartamenty
czarna ziemia
Teraz robimy ortofotomapy, które są zdjęciami z
wysokości z różnych stron zniszczonego
budynki z uszkodzonymi liniami
przenoszenie mocy przez mosty,
wymiary ustalamy w taki sam sposób jak z polami
lejek
rejestrujemy charakter zniszczenia kierowcy
że istnieje trajektoria pocisku i że
wszystko zostanie sprawdzone na poziomie międzynarodowym
równe zbrodnie Federacji Rosyjskiej przeciwko
ludność cywilna
[muzyka]
pod koniec 14 roku studiowałem
pilotować śmigłowce skrzydłowe w 15 roku
udał się do stref wojennych na wschodzie
Ukrainy wystąpi wieczorem
Ukraina potrzebuje dronów różnych typów
śmigłowce i rodzaj skrzydeł do wykonania
różne zadania zarówno z przodu, jak i na zewnątrz
ewakuacja ludności cywilnej w przypadku odejścia osoby
na ziemi i nie widzi tego z góry
dużo więcej szans na zdobycie
nieprzyjemność sytuacji w bitwie lub soli
Jeśli dana osoba ma przynajmniej informacje z góry
można zminimalizować utratę siły roboczej
jako że to odejście było drugim, znowu go zagłuszyłem
nie było satelitów, ale próbka została utracona Cóż
i szturmem, cóż, z Phantomem dobrze jest latać
teraz do naszego domu przyjeżdża nowy z satelitami
licznik
koło nadało temu procesowi nowy termin John
nie pada dużo, idąc do domu
mamy społeczność operatorów
UAV różnych typów Dzielimy się umiejętnościami
Dzielimy się naszym doświadczeniem, ponieważ teraz w
Nowe maszyny yaki przybywają na Ukrainę
które mają swoją specyfikę pracy, a które nie
można znaleźć Brak recenzji oprócz tego
w języku angielskim jest to bardzo rzadkie
maksymalny
plus ja pracuję
Cóż, teraz jest sesja szkoleniowa
loty żołnierzy Sił Zbrojnych Ukrainy w okolicach
warunki terenowe i w celu
wypracować taktykę prowadzenia wywiadu i
osłaniając strzelca, aby
w warunkach bitwy wszystko było tak bezpieczne, jak to tylko możliwe
i jak najszybciej
doświadczenie trzeba dzielić, doskonalić
różne typy UAV są koniecznością
uczyć tych, którzy dopiero zaczynają i robią
taka siatka w wojsku, żeby więcej ludzi
był w stanie bezpiecznie korzystać z dronów
to 20 jest różnych Na przykład, jeśli
zamknij się, jest zmiana zmiany i co
więcej osób wie jak to zrobić niż
więcej to ratuje życie
każdy dron ma swoją rezerwę czasu lotu
a potem trzeba naładować A gdzie
ładować, jeśli np. prąd
nie ma
im więcej ptaków, tym dłuższy czas
potrzebujemy takich helikopterów do lotu
Trudno było zniszczyć stacje wroga
walki radioelektronicznej, które zakłócają
praca dronów Dron może spaść Dron może
zgubić się Dron prawdopodobnie może iść dalej
trasa
potrzebujemy broni. Przyszli do nas
najeźdźcy z bronią, są uzbrojeni
wyprowadzeni i zabici w konfliktach z bronią
nasza lokalna ludność odwiedziła naszą
żołnierze zastrzelili nasze domy położnicze
szpitale szkoły zrobili to broń my
musimy w ten sposób opierać się bronią, ponieważ w
Jesteśmy w stanie wojny, potrzebujemy jakiejkolwiek broni
niebo mogło zostać zasłonięte bronią, która mogłaby:
zniszczyłby sprzęt wroga na odległość
niebezpieczne, aby wykryć tę technikę wroga
blokować jej pracę i neutralizować
to jedyny sposób, w jaki możemy wygrać
[muzyka]
Ukraina broni teraz nie tylko własnego
terytorium A także cały cywilizowany świat a
jeśli chcesz wesprzeć ukraiński
wojsko
skuteczna walka z wrogiem
kup i wyślij nam drony lub
wspierasz pieniędzmi zaangażowane fundusze
kupując Drony, te środki wracają
Pochodzenie i fundacja Serhija Prytuli żyją
Foy Ukraina
Nie, jestem na rękach
ok, chcesz
Dlaczego go zabieramy i co robić
[śmiech]